How are you? You may have noticed that we haven't uploaded a video in a while. Sorry, we've been extremely busy
We had half the week in nab then the second half we were rushing to do the shadow video
driving past the Ivanpah
concentrated solar power plant
Thousands and thousands of mirrors something like 180 thousand mirrors all reflecting the sunlight up to a single point up on this tower
and that tower is filled some Molten
Salt great for storing thermal energy it's like it's literally a thermal battery and so what they do is
They pipe water up through it and that turns to steam to power these turbines and those turbines turn to generate electricity
so [it] works during the night as well instead of like storing energy for solar panels into a battery its storing energy from the sun and in heat
see the power is a good chunk of laisse, so it puts out something like
370 Megawatts of Power
You got in walk up to the counters. We're all hey we got two reservations at the monte Carlo. [can] you help us out?
We don't [have] you guys on file then
After a little bit of searching, they're like
oh one of the run of the reservation is under nikko the other one search search called Ted got the
Reservation number that they got [from] and what name comes up?
But @TheColfud for those of you who don't know that's Carmichael's twitter name. which is on no ID at all and we run oh yeah
literally [I]
know
It's going to take ten minutes to get over there need to [know] where the aperture booth is it's Gonna be great
[sixty] [three] minutes. Why are why are we waiting around here some guys needed to go take a crap?
53 minutes
Just a minute 40 minutes
Got 30 minutes. We got 30 minutes to get our badges and then find the booth
Then we clark yeah, and then we're going to start
[lucid] right no bad fit the right place. Yeah
Like no, joke though you can walk pretty much non-stop for [three] straight days and still not [stupid] registration
A
Jig he bounces off [at] this [point]. We're fine. We got 20 [minutes] when I think less than 20 minutes to walk there. I hope
there
My God, sorry. [I] think I was going on. Yo it makes kitchen, right?
joking look well at the presentation [we] talked about how you can make your videos look more like Hollywood movies and we
Broke down some of our current lighting setup they're included showing off some of the shadow video ahead of time again
If you haven't seen the shadow video go check it out first link down below
Go : figure myself Emerson and others
Look uk equivalent
Battery Powerful 2k and look it's really not much bigger than the 1.0
Is it a little bit pretty funny that you guys had my twitter name
[oh], really
Okay, so I wanted to show you my process on doing some of these shadow effects in this video and the program I use is
called Adobe after effects and
This is the program that I pretty much do all of the effects work on the quarter channel in I've already dropped in the footage
That we're going to green-screen out and use as a shadow also
I'm going to be using this shortcut plug-in called effects console from video Copilot all I have to do is hit CTRL
Spacebar and then type in whatever effect
I want so when someone says I'm just going to green-screen that about what they really mean is the term teen so when you find?
Yourself in a situation where you need to erase?
parts of an image from a shot so you can isolate a single person what you do is you put them in front of a
green screen
And that's because as a uniform color
It's easier to race those pixels all at once and that is a process called
Keying the first thing you want to do is to mask out all the stuff. We're not really going to be utilizing
We're going to just mess that out, so if he light
I literally just grab the screen color click on the green and boom right off the bat. It does a pretty decent job
Go up to where it says
final results and switch that down to combined matte and [that'll] just give you a black and white image, and then I'm just going to
crank the contrast in a very sharp and opaque Black-And-white image
And if I type in extract we can actually key out the black part. It's like green screening
but for luminance values
So if the levels turn back on I'm just going to quickly cut out that white then we're going to apply one more
Effect called tint apply applied [10th]. I'm going to just tense everything to black now
We end up with a black shot with no background
It's completely transparent
So if I unsolo this now we have this layer and for all intents [and] purposes
This layer is going to act like
Footage when we got to nab we found out that the hotel had it booked the rooms for the correct days
The only logical thing to do was find a way to fix it
Crank Read
It is 8:30, and we're up and about we showered
I already went [workout] so a problem right now. Is that we are. I don't think we're staying here tonight unless that's been six
Meaning if we're not staying here tonight
We have to check out meaning that we have to take all of our stuff with us
There is a mix-up with in the tell right. They are able to get us work last night, but not tonight
I don't know what that is going to entail. Maybe we'll have to drive back to La tonight
That's not ideal, but I just texted them sort of her number
What hey what happened? What what happened last night? So what's the deal?
I have to be at extension by 11:00, so we got to go to the Westin hotel
That's our next row. So yes the original plan
According to carmichael is that we were driving home tonight? If [we] weren't able to get another [bill]. I got a hotel okay, cool
Yeah, now I know so you got to get all your stuff [here] ignore the [Westin]
Three-year-Old at x let's keep actually doing the trip for what eight less you oh?
Okay, which is far away. Come on the let's know you remember that then in front of it was the west gate hotel
That's where we gone far. [away]. Is it really under my name yeah?
Yeah, I just put down all of our names for two rooms okay, okay?
So I can check in [anytime]. Yeah
Yeah, literally hitting there right now. I'm missing an elevator now
Wait, what are [you] like [a] we're gonna play a joke [country] where we only have one we only have the room [for] one night
This was a joke the whole time. Are you serious?
So I don't [have] to go anywhere. [no]. God just do it. This [is] [curious]
Are we in the same room tonight? Yeah?
Hey
what is
this funny
did Nick oh
So he also packed [you] played a joke on him, [too]
You have your teeth no, I left because I thought I was leaving
Well, I know no mickey
Here's the thing though I actually do have [to] get there soon regardless of what house?
You do have it
What happen it read back what [why]?
Cuz we're not going anywhere. We got tonight here the fuck
So [coring] legit that'd be so funny to play a joke on us [making] it thing that we were going to have to leave tonight
I
Don't even define this now
We need to make it actually look like a shadow and belong in the shot my favorite way is to add a tenth effect
I'm actually just going to take this little eyedropper tool and
click on my shadow and boom now this layer is the exact same color as my shadow [a]
Good first step, but you'd see that the edges are really sharp
It doesn't really look like a shadow so we want to add a bit of fast Blur
We only want to blur it just a little [bit] cut we want to match these two shadows together now
We have the nice kind of soft edges to the shadow
But we need to match the noise of the real shadow and to do that
We're literally going to use the noise effect
Doesn't matter how good your camera is or what your exposure is you're going to have a little bit of noise
Especially in the shadows and when you add Cg objects to a scene you want to replicate that noise to make it seem [more] like
It was caught on camera rather than rendered out in [the] computer
Just kind of add in a little bit more of that gritty sharpness that the real footage has
So that's the basis of the effect if you want to do this yourself
It's actually pretty easy you literally just select the green color you know yeah
Just rinse and repeat for a 28 more shots and you got a shadow video
Please go [check] out the shadow video
We put a lot of work into it
And if you want we have a link to our subreddit down below where fans are able [to] talk to us more often
and